technique toujours mais moins dangereux
heureusement comment intéresser les plus
jeunes à l'ordinateur la cité des
sciences de la villette à paris associé
à des industriels de la spécialité
propos jusqu'au 8 janvier prochain une
exposition leur permettant de tester
tous les logiciels inédit qui sortent et
bien sûr essentiellement d'abord des
jeux muriel grade bousculades et
précipitation vers les écrans et les
claviers d'ordinateur quoi qu'on en
pense
les enfants adorent les jeux
informatiques avec la caution de la cité
des sciences pac man et les siens sont
sortis des bars et des salles de jeu
pour se transformer en outil pédagogique
pour 15 francs et pendant une heure les
jeunes peuvent tester une vingtaine de
généraux
nous avons voulu prononcer différents
matériels c'est en juin informatif que
l'on retrouvera ensuite dans les marchés
et pour pouvoir comparer nous semble
importante les enfants puissent comparer
les oeufs les principes de jeu aussi le
maniement
je suis sur la route et il faut que je
fasse le plus de kilomètres le score est
ici
là je vais me faire avoir par ce que je
faisais dans un arbre dans la
fascination pour les jeux informatiques
nous semblent aller dans l'air du temps
bien que l'informatique est un jeu
individuel et un enfant est face à son
écran une sorte de livre d'imagés
animées et puis il n'ya pas la notion d'
erreur de faute puisque à chaque fois
que londres atteint jeu en fait la
machine 17 revient départ et pour
l'enfant c'est extrêmement valorisant
pour m'indiquer des nuisances
examinerait il n'y a rien là dedans si
les techniques évoluent les thèmes peu
ne change pas jeu de course de combat ou
de guerre aux prises avec barbarians al
capone les jeunes tout en s'amusant
assimile le langage de l'ordinateur
l'opération ne concerne pas uniquement
les enfants c'est à la fois une vitrine
de nouveautés pour les plus avertis et
l'occasion de vérifier la fiabilité des
produits
ces logiciels sont vendus dans le
commerce entre 200 et 2000 francs